- Oh, this train's
coming right at me.
That's incredible.
Oh, my God! Oh!
[yelling]
- What have you done
with the morphine room?
- This is my dojo.
Pause.
- I know what you're doing,
Father Donahue, and I demand
that you stop taking advantage
of Lady Dodo's kind heart
and generosity.
- Or what?
- Or feel the full wrath
of Mr. Peepers.
- All right, Mr. Peepers.
Let me feel this wrath.
[guitar note resonates]
- A duel.
- A duel it is.
To the death.
Artistically speaking.
- [blowing]
Warm my fingers,
please, Garfield.
- Do you have one
of those glass things
you put on your finger?
- The duel was under
your initiation.
You begin.
- Fine.
Garfield, give us a C, please.
- [hums note]
[both strumming]
- Ooh, that's off.
That's off, isn't it?
- Yes.
- We'll just try that again.
[strumming tune]
It's probably easier
if I tune to you.
- Fine.
[both strumming]
[humming]
- Does that sound okay?
- [humming]
What note is that?
- I don't know.
- Do you know,
"Oh, He's My Savior,
Let Him Come Amongst Us"?
- Do you have a tuning fork?
- Do you know,
"Oh, Christ, Here He Is"?
- Do you know "Camptown Races"?
- Do you know, "Oh, Gay Are
The Days For He Is The One"?
- Do you know, "Champagne
Charlie Was His Name"?
- How does that go?
Is that--
- ♪ Champagne Charlie ♪
[both singing]
- Are you alone?
- Does it look like I'm alone?
- Yes.
- There are two other men
in this room.
- Yes, but I always
[bleep] in front of them.
- It's true.
- I've been very bad, Padre.
You may need to spank me.
- Frederick.
- Mmm?
- I will never,
ever make love to you.
Ever.
- [sobbing]
- We'll continue
this later, sir.
- Don't get on
my bad side, Peepers.
I intend to be here
for a very long time.